so let's talk about that after lunch
siesta where you want to take a nap and
why that is due to carbohydrates more
than any other reason now there are many
countries that take a siesta
and by the way siesta comes from the
Spanish word meaning nap and the Latin
word for sixth hour and that refers to
the countdown from dawn meaning midday
so there are many countries known for
these siestas Mexico certain countries
in South America Italy Philippines
Vietnam certain Mediterranean countries
southern Europe and Spain and of course
in America we don't really officially
say that we have a siesta but we
basically fall asleep in front of our
computer right after lunch
so the question is is it normal for
someone to get tired after eating now
there's actually a medical term for this
post prandial which means after a meal
zomlings and that means food comma and
of course this is a common feature for
diabetes so when you have the
combination of especially refined
carbohydrates and volume of calories
together it can really create a blood
sugar spike and an insulin spike both of
these are going to make you tired now
the question is why would they make you
tired
there's several mechanisms going on that
go beyond the insulin resistance
mechanism where you're having a lack of
fuel go into the cell alright number one
you activate something called the
parasympathetic nervous system so
there's two parts of the autonomic
nervous system you know the sympathetic
which is flight-or-fight and the
parasympathetic which is rest and digest
so when you eat a lot of food especially
we're falling carbohydrates you're going
to activate this system over here and
inhibit this system and you're going to
want to take a nap so that would be the
gut brain connection and with that
you're going to have less blood to the
brain and more blood into the digestive
system so try to be awake when you don't
have the amount of blood to the brain
it's a little more difficult all right
three decreases the arousal pathways in
the hypothalamus in the brain making you
tired
and number four and this is interesting
when you consume a high carb diet you're
gonna absorb certain amino acids but not
others specifically you're gonna absorb
valine leucine isoleucine but not
tryptophan so tryptophan is going to be
absorbed through the blood-brain barrier
and it's gonna directly turn into
serotonin and melatonin the sleep
hormone so if you live in any one of
these countries or in the US I want you
to try an experiment like in Mexico you
would have tortillas and corn based type
things rice Italy you're gonna have
pasta Philippines in Vietnam you're
gonna have rice noodles the
Mediterranean you're gonna have more
pasta and bread southern Europe well you
might have potatoes or some other starch
and in Spain you're gonna have more
carbs so here's a challenge try and not
consuming carbohydrates at your lunch
for one week and you're going to find
your energy is going to go straight up
the need for a nap is not going to be
there and for those of you that are new
to my channel check out this video on
low carbs it will tell you exactly what
to eat